-So, last time you were here,
we were talking about
your show "Revenge."
And I feel like, in this show,
it's safe to say,
you are actually
playing a character
who has a moral compass.
-Yes, she has a moral compass.
Thank God.
-Do you enjoy that? Do you enjoy
playing a person who's kinder?
-She's still tough,
but it's nice
that she has, as you say,
a moral compass.
She's got a tremendous amount
of integrity.
And I just, like,
was really drawn to that
after four years
of playing this nut.
You know?
-Yes.
It's nice to get out of
the nut game.
Yeah, of course.
-You need a little break.
-Diversify, yeah.
-Exactly.
-Did you spend time with people
in the medical profession
to prepare for this?
-Yeah. I mean, you have to.
You can't really shadow because
it's strange, you know?
I wouldn't want that.
-I would not want my doctor
to come in and be like --
"Here's actress Emily VanCamp.
She's shadowing me today."
That's strange.
But I spoke to nurses and
nurse practitioners at length
and, you know,
mostly just wanted
to get to know what a day
looks like for them.
You know, when do you cry
as a nurse?
You know, like, when do you --
All of the little things
you don't think about.
-Sure.
-And it was just
a fascinating process.
And, gosh, do I have -- Oh, hey.
Rookie mistake.
No, I mean, I just --
I found them fascinating.
I have so much respect
for medical professionals,
not that I didn't before.
But, my God, they're noble.
-Is it true that
you've been watching
YouTube videos
of gruesome surgeries?
-Dude. [ Chuckles ] It's rough.
-Yeah, well, what's rough
is now YouTube's gonna start
suggesting other things
for you to watch.
-I know. No. It already does.
Things pop up,
and I'm like, "Oh, God!"
No, but I am a little bit
less squeamish now.
It's weird.
Like, I was sort of just
kind of doing some research
the other night.
We have this procedure
we have to do
which is cutting into an eyelid
and then an eyeball.
And I just found myself --
I'm serious.
I found myself just, like,
nonchalantly watching it.
Our nurse who helps us out
sent it over,
and I'm just, like,
watching this procedure,
and I realized, "Oh, my God.
I'm just doing this."
-Wow.
"I'm just doing it,
and I've got no feeling."
I was numb to it. It's amazing.
So I don't know.
Maybe I'm just indirectly --
-Yeah, you either
are getting better
or you've turned into
a sociopath.
-That too. So...
-Does your mom have trouble
watching the show?
-She does.
-Okay.
-Most of my family,
except my sister
who's studying to be a vet.
She's like, "I got this."
But, you know, we all kind of
think we have all the ailments.
-Oh, I see.
-So every script I read,
I'm like, "Oh, my God, Mom!
I'm pretty sure I have this,
I'm pretty sure I have that!"
And she's like,
"I have that, too!"
Thanks. That's helpful.
But, yeah, it's definitely been
a test for me to do this show.
And I'm learning a huge amount,
which is kind of cool.
-I know you and your family
are huge hockey fans.
You are shooting in Atlanta
right now.
-No hockey team.
They have a soccer team,
but they can't have --
They used to have a hockey team.
-Yeah, they used to have one.
Now, is it hard for you --
What is your team?
-The Canadiens.
-The Canadiens. Gotcha.
-'Cause I studied in Montreal.
-Gotcha.
-But they're huge rivals
with Toronto,
and, you know,
I'm from Toronto, so, yeah.
I mean, I get, like, hate mail
from my family constantly.
-Oh, wow.
Well, still, it's nice of them
to write a letter
in this day and age.
Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
And it's, like, very
Canadian-style hate mail.
So it's like, you know --
It's not too bad.
-It's like, "You're going down.
Also, I hope you're well."
-Yes, exactly. Yes.
Exactly. Exactly.
Also, "Can't wait to see you."
-So, hard to keep up?
-It is because I don't have
actual television in Atlanta.
I just have streaming.
So I'm always --
My mom updates me
'cause she's actually a
Canadiens fan, as well.
-Gotcha.
-So things get a little heated.
-Well, it's nice that you can
stay a family unit despite this.
-Exactly. Exactly.
-We did not talk about
this last time you were
here because you --
I'm not sure,
but you have certainly been
in a "Captain America" movie
since you've been here.
-Yeah, I don't think
I was in --
-How is -- And here's a photo.
You are in this photo.
-I am somewhere.
I'm like on the end somewhere.
There I think I am.
-This is the Marvel class photo
of everybody who's been
in a Marvel film,
and it's an incredible
group of people.
How has the experience
been for you?
-It's been amazing.
I mean, everyone's incredible.
The movies are so amazing,
so it's just incredible
to be a part of them.
But then being on that stage
was just weird.
I was like,
"What am I doing here?"
Like, who said to call
Emily VanCamp?
'Cause I'm like,
"This is crazy."
It was so fascinating.
-It's a weird thing because --
That's like more famous people
than are at any given Oscars.
-It's so many famous people
and so many people
that I respect and love.
And I just kind of was just
sort of standing there in awe.
It was very cool.
And those movies
are just awesome.
-They're great. I know there's
a high level of secrecy
when you work on a film
like that, but is there --
-I have like, a silent drone
following me around right now.
-Are you allowed
to take souvenirs
from the set at the end?
-I mean, not me.
And I wouldn't even try.
I mean, that's scary.
-Or take, like, a really
low-level prop, like a pencil.
-I mean, I probably
could take a pencil,
but even then, somebody would be
like -- They know everything.
No, but it's -- Yeah --
I didn't even attempt.
-Gotcha.
-I was just really happy
to be there,
and I did not want to
ruffle any feathers.
-Very smart. Very smart.
Wait, like, 'til
your third or fourth movie
and then steal something.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. Exactly.
-Steal the shield
and get out of there.
I know you're also
a poker player.
This is something --
-I am, yeah.
-And when did your love
of poker start?
-I started young.
I started as a teenager.
-Okay, that's good. I think most
poker players probably did.
-Back when I was doing
"Everwood,"
that's what we would do because
we were shooting in Utah,
and I just fell in love with it.
I mean, I don't play in casinos
or the games or anything.
-I feel like Utah would be
heartbroken to find out
that because you were there
you became a gambler.
-I think there are oddly
a lot of gamblers there.
-Okay, that makes sense.
That tracks, yeah.
-But, yeah, I love it.
It's a great game.
And that's what I do
with my friends.
You know, we just...
-Gotcha.
-...get around a poker table,
and it's good fun.
-Do you think
you could actually beat --
like, take down
some professionals?
Are you at that level?
-I've never tried.
-I feel like this is --
I feel like you're playing coy,
but you could.
You're like, "I don't know.
I'd love to play,
though, gentlemen."
-I'm just joining
the World Poker Tour.
No, I don't know
if I'm at that level,
but I've been playing
for a long time.
-All right.
You never know then.
Hey, thanks so much
for being back.
It's such a pleasure
to see you again.